we didn't look at it as a consumer
device our initial reaction was WOW
wouldn't this be amazing is sort of an
industrial device as a portal through
which people who are conducting Commerce
can ask questions about a complicated
company or complicated organization and
get immediate and relevant answers could
you in fact take one of these amazon
echoes presently there about one hundred
and eighty dollars i want to say 160
hundred seventeen hundred eighty dollars
that's relatively cheap it's cheap
enough to where you could deploy this
technology on every desk in in every in
an office building or every conference
room let's say so that that begins to
sort of get a little more exciting to us
so are the question that we pose to
ourselves is could we take the Wolfram
language which we love and we know can
help distill really complex problems and
really complex systems and can we sort
of both that to the Amazon echo in some
way so that we're not interacting with
models in the traditional way of sort of
bringing it up on your computer and
typing in some parameters or sliding
some sliders and clicking some button
and having some output but rather we're
speaking something and whether that
answer to that something is in the form
of off-the-shelf data fine if it's in
the form of a model in other words to
answer the person asking you questions a
question I have to go run a model and
then return that back to them the person
asking the question doesn't care they
just want the answer to their question
so could we build a system like that
because if we could that opens up lots
and lots of possibilities which I'll
talk about in a minute so we we took it
on ourselves to to do that and again
this was before Todd's work Todd galleys
work in with his special package so we
what I'm going to do is kind of take you
through a little bit through the journey
of how we how we went through that so
yeah the basic idea is yeah sorry that
that's so
mall the rest of my slides are a little
bit bigger so you'll be able to see them
but you know essentially the idea is you
know can we do things verbally is so
instead of typing can we can we speak it
and even if we speak it impartial E or
improperly can the system sort of still
figure that out so we get a lot of
opportunities to watch people we build
models for interact with these models
and again it's it's it's an unnatural
thing so we might build a model let's
say of a pricing formula we did this not
long ago and it helped our client who's
in the retail business price certain
products and it was a pretty complicated
formula took into a lot of factors and
you plug in a lot of parameters and says
okay for this you know widget that's you
know ten dollars and ninety-nine cents
okay fine so watching people you know
interact with this model well first they
had to find the model somewhere it was
on some server somewhere they had to
pull it up and then they had to in fact
type in those parameters they had to hit
some button you know it was it was a bit
of an exhausting process when we were we
were in sort of a meeting with one of
the people on the the client side and
they said well why can't I just I want
to know what should be the price of
product x I just want to know that so so
why did he want to know that question
well because he had several questions
about that whole class of products that
are that were to be priced so it got us
thinking about well how do humans human
beings really want to interact with
intelligent systems well I'll tell you
how they they don't they don't do it
unnaturally like I just described it
starts with this sort of broad general
question what is the nature of X and
then you get an answer to that question
and usually they answer to that question
then inspires you to ask the next
question and then that answer inspires
you to ask the next and so on so what
humans tend to follow a line of
reasoning so if we can figure out how to
take the friction out of dealing with
models
I you know devices like like the Amazon
echo great you know we might get to a
point where not only are we building
really intelligent systems but we're
doing something even better which is
making those intelligent systems a lot
more accessible to people who just
Harbor some kind of question that they
that they want answered which by the way
is the vast majority of people sort of
outside this room this is a really
important question for us I think
because it's it's it is about how
intelligent the solution is but it's
just as much about how you deliver that
solution so you know along comes the
Amazon echo and then of course the
difference between the Amazon echo and
other similar devices I mean people talk
about Siri and so forth is its open
architecture it allows you to I'd
mention these skills essentially a skill
is almost like extending the vocabulary
of the device so I could I could ask the
device I'll turn it off mute here for a
minute I hope you can hear it and i'll
just ask some sort of random questions
so Alexa what is 2 to the power of 32 2
to the power of 32 is four billion 294
million nine hundred sixty seven
thousand 296 you already knew that that
that that answer I'm sure so that that's
that's in it's sort of base vocabulary
if you will what you do is you you add
skills and Jesse covered this a little
bit in her talk this morning you had
skills to a skill is essentially an app
or in our case it's a model or it's just
maybe as a series of bottles so it's
intelligent about this domain of
something you could make it intelligent
about this domain of something by adding
these skills essentially adding to its
vocabulary so this was the notion that
sort of guided us to you know hour later
experiment so we had a company
approached us and this is an interesting
company they they're in the
large business so if you've ever been in
a big river system the Ohio River
Mississippi River tennessee river etc
see these big barges sort of move this
this company had the highest market
share of any inland barge company so at
any given moment they've got thousands
maybe even hundreds of thousands of
these barges sort of moving all over the
United States and they wanted to be a
had this big data set every 15 seconds
or so they log what what a given barge
or vessel is doing so they wanted to be
able to ask questions of this data set
and they said well the current way that
we ask questions of this data set is we
have to go to this database and and or
it's on some kind of obscure scorecard
it's just a really difficult and again
friction filled way to ask questions we
want to be able to ask questions in sort
of a natural language way so they handed
us a sample of data in a sample of data
look just like this so it was just it
was literally an Excel spreadsheet it
was 30 megabytes in length it was a 30
day window of all of their vessel
movements you can see that there's some
vessel out there and this event code
might be its docking or its refueling or
it stopped for weather or you know all
those different kind of things that
could happen to a barge from you know
point A to point B so we said well can
we in effect curate I'm using that that
that term a little bit loosely can we
curate this data in such a way that we
can make it amenable to to the echo so
the first thing that we had we were
confronted with was figuring out this
whole Alexa ecosystem it's not a simple
endeavor the Amazon Web Services is this
enormous domain of various services that
all connect together in various ways
Jesse mentioned the lambda service
that's that sort of big block up there
to the left and there's Alexa voice
services there's something called an
utterance that's the actual speaking
string and then there's an intent okay
based on what you uttered what you know
what you really want and and so you we
had to learn all of this vocabulary and
I'm not here to kind of go over though
that vocabulary I wasn't originally but
I'm really not
because Todd's now made that sort of all
material now because you can actually go
you kind of bypass a lot of this
plumbing and go more directly which
which is a great thing about about
Todd's work but but for us it took us
you know maybe a couple of months to
sort of go through all this and figure
out what was going on now at the end of
this long string you see the law firm
language in fact we have our own
instance of private cloud and so we we
deployed functions because and this is
an important conversation and and there
was a comment I think made earlier this
morning about what what is the you could
have used python in here you know why
you know Wolfram language in this that's
a very good question and for us I think
the answer is it's really about
computation yeah sure we could have we
could have used python if we wanted to
but in in terms of breaking down a
question I'd much rather have the
computation horsepower of the Wolfram
language than something like Python
which would have been what Jessie many
many other lines of code to to do all of
that so
[Music]
not to mention the fact that you know
there's there's another thought about
bringing Wolfram Alpha functions into
the mix here that I think would be
helpful so you know I think having the
Wolfram language they're just sets us up
to do a lot more things with it and I'll
go over some of those a little bit later
all right so now let's let's let's let's
do something sort of interesting here
you know I've always admired you Steven
doing sort of these live demos and
taking the risk of of doing that so
let's let's try to do that now what I'm
going to do excuse me I'm going to grab
my little piece of paper script here so
I make sure I read all these things
correctly you you do have to be a little
persnickety about how you interact with
the echo one of the things that we
encountered this these little funny tips
and tricks is it's not good with proper
names Bob Mary Sally and of course all
these vessels had these proper names and
it like didn't know what we were talking
about now there are ways around that I
was talking with Todd I think they're in
if you're building applications that use
sort of proper names in this way or
non-english turnin on cogent English
terms or whatever they call that there
are ways around that but it was a tricky
bit so i'm going to i'm going to ask it
i'm going to ask it a series of three
questions and the first question I'm
going to ask is you know kind of the
distance the average distance between
two locations and I'm going to give them
numbers instead of the proper names
instead of you know like like Little
Rock to Baton Rouge it kind of struggles
with that so i'm going to use names i'm
also going to ask about i'm actually
going to ask about a boat named angelina
and what it was doing on week three and
i'm also going to ask about a certain
location number which is a port on a
particular day and what happened on that
particular port now the reason I'm
telling you what I'm going to ask is
because i want to ask these in
succession because that one of the other
things that we did
with the echo is we password-protected
it so a lot of our the companies that we
talked to about this kind of capability
have said well you know what if the the
janitor is actually a Russian spy they
didn't really say that and you know
walks in and you know sort of asked all
these questions crazy questions about
our company and then and then sends that
that results to you know the mother
country or something we said all right
well fine so we'll we'll actually have a
verbal password the thing about the echo
2 is that it does not distinguish voices
so it doesn't know me versus anybody
else talking to it so there's no sort of
voice signature thing but so it's an
interesting question yet unsolved by us
about you know what you do about
security of these things if they're sort
of hanging around in every sort of
conference room and and in every office
so so so which password protected so so
to keep me from having to enter my
password every time i ask something i'm
going to ask them kind of in succession
so i'm going to tell you what I'm going
to ask I'm going to ask three questions
that I'm going to follow up with a
fourth question here in a minute so
let's give it a whirl see if it works
this Wi-Fi network has not been our
friend this week so everybody say a
silent prayer that this is actually
going to work Alexa port report welcome
to business laboratory and telling
report please speak username and
password George 230 name and password
not recognized username George password
1230 yep try to get please speak
username and password George 230 welcome
back George what report would unite
location number 9940 and location number
2247 the average transit time between
9940 and 2247 is 15 hours and 23 points
0 minutes and with a standard deviation
of 38 hours and 20 3.0 minutes angelina
on
week three the vessel Angelina has 12
events for week three and March location
number 9940 date March third 2016 the
location with identification 9940 had
137 events from month 3 and a 3 okay so
all that was from the data set that I
just mentioned to you so it was a fairly
straightforward process to go from that
data and and now it's able to sort of
answer these questions goodbye ok now
that so that was really interesting and
it was fun to do and we were kind of
surprised at at how effective that was I
mean she missed a lot of my verbal
talked about generally speaking this is
way better than Cirie in terms of the
the voice accuracy so we wanted to go
just a little bit further here and I'm
going to try to leave room for questions
we wanted to see if if we could do
things to it visually and audibly so
this is something that Todd didn't do so
Nana and we're doing better than you
which is I so you're getting a verbal
response as well as a visual response to
this so some of the people that work at
the company are big fans of iron man
they got a thought oh that's just cool
this is going to be just like Jarvis so
he said well all right let the can this
can this be done so here we go so let me
mute it for a second oh okay let me see
if I can okay that's it I think that's
going to be all right all right so this
is a graph of vessel time at Port it's
kind of doing a moving average and so
forth and so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to ask for a different vessel and
it'll recalculate as I talk to it so
let's let's give this a try Alexa
port report welcome to business
laboratory and telling report please
speak username and password George 230
compute vessel time at port and there we
go ok so now week it's got hooks in here
so that you can give it both a parallel
audible response as well as a visual
response and I think that that this is a
like a really powerful idea so we were
just getting started but we're
incredibly incredibly enthusiastic about
all the different applications that that
are here you know Jesse mentioned a few
this morning you know corporations with
an appliance on every desk wouldn't that
be kind of an amazing capability if if
you're sitting here in in Tesla and and
you could ask the question well what was
our production yesterday or what were
our costs on X and and just get an
immediate answer so I had a chance to
talk to a few sergeant friends of mine
and I asked them does it ever you know
come up that you need information during
surgery they say this comes up all the
time and so they're painting this
picture where you know you're you're
doing surgery and you're cutting open
Miss Smith and you know you look it
inside and you notice a lesion on her
small intestine intestine and you know
you'd love to nokia have we ever had any
patients without type blood age thus and
such and you know have this condition
and you want something to say oh well
there have been four hundred eighty two
cases of this that would be that would
be amazing right now they have a human
being at a computer in some of their
more complex surgery doing this kind of
thing sometimes they don't even have
that so they just have to sort of keep
going wouldn't it be nice to have one of
these devices where they could ask that
so we're having some conversations about
that you know process plants and
factories anywhere where gee I want to
up to up to the minute sort of
information the other thing that's
that's brought up about the echo and
everything you sort of read and think
about the echo is all always this sort
of
I'm going to ask a question and I get a
response but wouldn't it be nice if the
thing actually talked to you without
prompting so what if you could say Alexa
they wanted to yell at me I'm sorry I
did yeah cuz I don't want to respond
when i say Alexa is that I do that you
know when I talk about Alexa you know
she's I didn't understand what you said
which the same response I get from my
wife so I don't know but wouldn't it be
nice if you you know it sent you
information without you prompting it
with a question so take the corporation
metaphor what if you could say Alexa
anytime my competitor cuts their price
by five percent I want you to send me an
email oh by the way I want you to run my
revenue model and send it to my five
vice presidents or you know something
like that well that's a very legitimate
thing to do and then it would just it
would just follow that that trigger in
an ifft kind of way we think that's
that's nice what this thing is always
listening so if it's prompted by some
information or some conference
conversation in a meeting wouldn't it be
great if it offered some helpful
observation about something that you
were some topic that you were talking
about I mean it so we're definitely sort
of looking into this whole idea of push
and as I mentioned sort of the ifft like
capability where I can verbally you know
if if then if this then that how many of
you have heard of this it's a it's well
most of you so it's a consumer app that
basically allows you to build these
recipes that sort of our triggered
automatically well that that's awesome
but what what if you know what if you
wanted to just store a recipe that comes
up in in you know as a topic in some
meeting you turn to your your to turn to
Alexa and you create a recipe on the fly
and then she's also the channel through
which that recipe gets triggered when
when some event of note happens so we're
obviously looking into that as well so
there's tons and tons and tons of
applications I think I went way over
time and I apologize so i'll i'll stop
here and i'll ask for any questions
thank you very much
[Applause]